la saison de crabe des neiges débute à
peine et c'est aujourd'hui l'une des
espèces les plus lucratives ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas
à une autre époque les pêcheurs je t'ai
ce crustacé carrément par dessus bord un
reportage de 1989 retracer les hauts et
les bas de cette industrie
[Musique]
quand
non
au début des années 60 le crabe des
neiges vient s'ajouter aux espèces de
crustacés à laure pécher dans le golfe
saint laurent
il s'agissait pourtant alors de prises
accidentelles fait lors de la pêche aux
poissons de fond comme la morue le
sébaste au départ on pêche le crabe des
neiges un peu à l'est de la baie des
chaleurs
ensuite dans les eaux près de la côte
nord des îles de la madeleine et de
l'île du cap-breton jusqu'au milieu des
années 80 les prises sont en forte
hausse
puis elle dégringole c'est que l'on
connaît alors bien peu ce crustacé dont
les populations fluctue selon des cycles
naturels la fermeture hâtive de la
saison de pêche cette année est due à
une mue précoce du crabe des neiges
l'apparition du crabe blanc celui qui
viennent lui et exige qu'il fallait
cesser la pêche de façon à assurer la
permanence destin
[Musique]
au fil des ans l'imposition de quotas de
pêche et une connaissance accrue de la
biologie de l'espèce ont permis une
meilleure gestion des stocks
aujourd'hui les populations de crabe des
neiges se porte bien et le réchauffement
de long et la diminution du couvert de
glace en hiver modifie l'habitat de ce
crustacé qui aiment l'eau froide
plusieurs scientifiques craignent donc
que les crabes ne migre peu à peu vers
le nord ce qui viendrait bouleverser
l'économie de certains villages côtiers
[Musique]